hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game also from round four of
the 2013 candidates tournament we have a
game between Boris Gelfand and vastly
von Schuch now for a lot of you this
will be the first time that you see this
game but this game is absolutely amazing
and it features one move that is that is
really incredible it's like the ultimate
calculated bluff / brilliancy you'll see
what I mean and also we do have some
photos from this round and we'll talk
about the standings after the game so
here we have a couple of photographers
they are they are actually taking photos
of a sleeve and choke here and you can
see vastly there he's like oh come on
guys I know I'm a star but take some
photos of Magnus as well and so they did
and here we have a photo of Boris
Gelfand this is a photo before the game
even started so you can see that
piercing gaze it's you know who knows
what he looks like you know when there's
actually something going on on the board
and this is and this is Yvonne - before
the game started he's having trouble
deciding which pen to use to actually
write it down the moves so a lot of
different strategies so let's see this
game a Giffen opens with the d4 and as
you'll see one will employ a very old
variation the sugaring defense
we have d5 and c4 so we have the queen's
gambit on the board and eventual goes
for Knight to c6 the Chi go in defense
and here what it does have a couple of
options the capturing on d5 immediately
is not considered that great for for
white because after Queen captures let's
say you defend a pawn black and black
and very easy force a variation that
will be somewhat equal but will leave a
white with an isolated D pawn so Knight
to c3 attacking the Queen Bishop to b4
now pinning the night and after e3
captures captures captures captures
captures captures and it's pretty cool
position but you know black has like has
two point islands White has three point
islands and an isolated the D pawn maybe
if you really enjoy isolated point you
can you can play this with white but
white
really doesn't achieve anything here so
after Knight to c6 gave and played
Knight to f3
we have Bishop to g4 Knights the C 3 e 6
Bishop to f4 Bishop captures on f3 g
captures on f3 and Bishop to b4 by
venture so obviously get Fonda is not
gonna Castle King King side anytime soon
and it's a question if he will Castle
queenside so we have III Knight G to e7
Queen to c2 making room for a
queen-sized castling D captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and Knight to d5
now if I took attacks at the pin piece
on c3 and also he would definitely enjoy
playing Knight captures on f4 tripling
White's pawns of course the elephant
will not allow this gush up to g3 and we
have h5 preparing age for h3 Queen to d7
event you also prepares queenside castle
and now we do have it Queens our castle
by gelfand and queenside castle by
Evancho's Knight to e4 here came to be
it also white falls in this example King
to be one always a useful move extra
defense of these 8 points and also you
don't really want your King on an open
file or or or in Black's case on the
hunt is diagonal same as the Queen so h4
Bishop to h2 and the now Bishop to d6 a
very interesting moment in the game if I
took either offers a trade of bishops so
Bishop captures Bishop captures or he
offers Knight captures on e6
on d6 which would which would leave
white with the bishop pair and here
elephant goes for a very interesting
decision he plays f4 which keeps the
tension on the board and this is a very
strong knight on e4 but it kind of locks
out this Bishop from the game on h2 and
so eventually immediately takes
advantage of this he plays f5 walking
this pawn on f4 so for now this Bishop
is kind of useless
we have Knight to g5 nice to a5
attacking the bishop Bishop to e2 and
now rook back to c8 now even trick is
planning to bust open the C file
Queen to d2 we have Bishop to b4
attacking the Queen Queen to d3 and now
c 5d captures on c5 rook captures on c5
and now p4 and this is the critical and
really a great moment in this game get
from the tax event ryx knight on d5 so
what do you do here well there are there
are a lot of things you could enjoy
doing but what if one who played is
absolutely brilliant
he plays rook H to c8 so he gives up a
knight on d5 and what's the idea here
well the idea is that black will get a
really a really beautiful attack if
white actually captures it but capturing
the knight is the strongest move
unfortunately forget fun the elephant
that did not play this move Jeff and did
not play it because it's it's extremely
complicated to calculate this and
eventual was in severe time trouble in
this game so he ventricle already lost
two games in this tournament due to due
to time control he ran out of time and
this game he is also in serious time
trouble so perhaps Griffin did not want
to calculate this as he wants to disband
really a lot of time calculating rook H
to c8 but it's not all that clear if you
if you want you're free to pause this
position and see how this works for
white and the white works but I will
also show it it's really I mean this is
if you found this you you're you know
much better player than me and then then
most of the players but e captures on d5
is really dangerous what also works for
white due to rook captures here and now
the only move that works for white is
Queen to f3 after Queen to f3 black
plays rook captures only one rook
captures and now comes the Shocker Queen
capture Sun b1 this comes with Czech
Bishop captures on d1 and now Knight the
c-4 the threat is of course night to d2
checking the king this will also form
the queen and this is probably probably
guess one saw the position until here
and he didn't like it
but it would truly take Tigran Petrosian
to play this position now you have to
play King to see - and what's the
defense for white after night the D -
check this discovers this opens up a
discovered check from the rook also the
queen is now attacked the knight is
protected by the bishop and who now
comes queen to c3 this is the defensive
idea and after Bishop captures on c3
pawn captures on c3 and the knight moves
Bishop to e2 Knight moves now white
would have two bishops for a rook and
and he would be in a better position
after you after we activate the h2
bishop of course but you know going into
this it would take someone who really
you know likes to punish himself or or
he's like the greatest defensive player
Petrosyan did come to mind so after this
rook each to see it move by one Chuck
gelfand actually doesn't accept this
piece he plays rook to see one rock to
see one and now if I should plays Knight
to c4 and now the position is completely
crazy what do you do here you can you
don't really have time for a slow move
or even to capture the knight now if you
capture the knight now then Knight the
d2 wins the game immediately for black
after night the d2 check we don't really
have a move here you can either capture
the night with the Queen you lose the
Queen after Bishop captures or you can
go King get one and then it's simply
game over rook captures b1 checkmate
so get funded of course a great player
as he is he found he found a very nice
idea he played rook captures on c4 rook
captures on c4 and now he captures on d5
we have a pawn captures on d5 and now
Queen to b3 here inventor played Queen
to c6 now with this beautiful Rock Queen
rook battery on the C file and it's only
moved 26 and Yvonne took is down to only
two minutes on the clock so it's it's
gonna be hard he has to make 14 more
moves in two minutes
so this is the third game that Yvonne
took is you know almost losing done time
Bishop captures on c4 we have pawn
captures on c4 attacking the Queen
and now Queen to f3 offering a trade of
Queen's White has to play very actively
he can't really allow c3 so
Queen to b5 eventually declines of
course the trade of Queens and is
preparing to push c3 Queen to e2 now
preventing c3 because now then Queen
captures Queen is an idea and if you
look at this position even ship is still
down a full piece but this rook on h1 is
still undeveloped the bishop on h2 is
not going to be developed anytime soon
and the knight and g5 is a bit stranded
you know yeah okay he can get back into
the game but at the moment he's not
really doing anything so rook to e8 if I
took a taxi elephants Queen Queen to c2
and now c3 finally by land choke and
again you have to be very careful here
if you play something like b3 then rook
to e2 is coming and you're losing this
game Quincy 1 check King moves and now
Queen to c5 threatening Queen to c3
checkmate after we prevent this then
Bishop to e3 simply wins the Queen and
the game so after c3 virtual campy
captures on c3 and Bishop captures on c3
so you have two options here you have
King to c1 and Queen to b3 in the game
Griffin did give it a serious thought
and it did take him a while to decide
how to defend against the Avengers great
threat but he decided to play Queen to
b3 and after Queen to d3 Gelfand
repeated moves Queen c2 Queen to b5
Queen to b3 and after Queen to c2 Queen
b5 they agreed to draw as it was a
threefold repetition so it doesn't
matter a bunch of with extremely low on
time but engagement also got into time
trouble and he couldn't figure out if if
it was safe to play King to see one but
it's a good thing that he didn't because
King to see one loses terribly for white
also a very nice position get fun didn't
play it who knows if he saw it and maybe
he just didn't have time to calculate it
but he decided not to play it which is
of course very nice if you if you don't
have time to calculate mating attack
don't expose your King without a reason
but it's a very nice puzzle for you to
solve you know
if you like attacking especially so
there are actually two attacking ideas
here that work feel free to pause the
video and find either one of them or
both of them even better so I will get a
couple of seconds for you to decide for
those of you who were able to solve this
congratulations you are an excellent
attacker and for those of you who want
to enjoy the show
there are two ideas like we said one is
rook to c8 there's a queen and c2 and
King and c1 of course you would like a
look and see it and now you're
threatening all sorts of discoveries
with the bishop doesn't really matter
where you move the bishop white will
lose this but yeah okay let's see a
couple of ideas if King tries to run
King B 1 then you get Queen to d5 check
ok if King moves to c1 then simply Queen
captures on h1 and this will soon be
over Kim has the move you grab the Queen
and it's all over
but after Queen d5 check ok you don't
have to go to King c1 you can even go
kinky too but it doesn't help
rook e8 check now you can't go to f3 you
have to go to it to f1 and now rook to
e1 this will be checkmate as the Queen
is covering g2 another interesting idea
after this Queen d5
not after Queen D 5 instead of rock to
see it was if you found a Bishop b2
check immediately this also works
because if you capture with the Queen if
Queen captures then you get rock to c8
check King moves and now Queen to be 1
check King moves and now rook to e8
check the King cannot come to d3 or f3
as the Queen is blocking those squares
so we have to go King to f3 and then
Queen to h1 is a beautiful checkmate as
the rook is covering the entire if file
and another thing after a bishop to d2
if you did find this King - if King
captures and d2 is also an option but
then of course you can see that rook to
eat two wins immediately King moves rope
capture screen captures and then Queen
to c6 check check the King and grabs the
rook and then it's a completely winning
game if
even funnier after the key moves in you
captured the rook there's actually no
way to save this bishop because in
knight of trees impossible the queen is
preventing the knight from coming to f3
so that's even worse this Bishop really
did not you know show anything this game
you know it was really a useless piece
so when you once you've sacrificed a
piece he actually realized that to get
fun sacrificed a piece long before him
but iam after Queen to be five a draw
with a greet here and elephants saw that
playing something like King to see one
simply doesn't work so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and after
this game although this was a draw I
mean it's a water draw you know and some
that's why I said it as some of you
might not have seen this game because
you know because it was drawn but it's
it would be a shame not to see such a
game and after this game cross and did
win his game in round four but all of
the other games were drawn so after
round four cross and caught up to Aaron
and so it's cause I'm in Aragon in first
place and in second place it's a Peter
Svidler
alone by himself so a very intense
tournament so far and as usual I will
put a link in the description below with
a very nice article but Peter Dodgers
where you can check out a little bit
about every game and also there will be
some nice photos in the link also in the
description below so do check that out
so yeah I think y'all for watching as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I will see you soon
hopefully I will get back to my hometown
bye bye
Wednesday and then then we'll have some
nice videos from round 5 of the 2013
candidates tournament see you soon